when people use the terms fascism or
fascist today they're usually using it
in a derogatory way to refer to a a
group a regime or even an individual
that is overly aggressive and
controlling and totalitarian but its
roots actually lie with Benito Mussolini
who was in power in Italy during the
1920s and 1930s and through World War
two and they proudly called themselves
the fascists and their ideology as
fascism and the word fash or the root of
fascist and fascism come from the
Italian word fascio which literally
refers to a bundle it comes out of this
idea that a bundle of things will be
stronger together than individually and
this is actually the symbol for fascism
and and this this symbol of this bundle
this sheaf of sticks this actually
predates Mussolini by thousands of years
it goes back to Roman times and even
based on some of the things I've read
even predates Roman times as a symbol of
of unity a string a symbol of official
strength and even before Mussolini came
around the term was used by many many
many groups that view themselves as a a
League of revolutionaries a a group of
people somehow fighting for change and
Mussolini was no different when in
nineteen the end of 1914 and then in
early 1915 he establishes the fasci
di Sione River Lucien Aria and I'm once
again so sorry for my my butchering of
an Italian word but this literally
translates to group action revolutionary
or you could say the revolutionary
action group founded by Mussolini in
1915 and it was really a splinter of the
Socialist Party when there's an irony
there because Mussolini and fascism in
particular is associated with strongly
anti socialist ideology but as we enter
into or as Europe was entering into
World War
in 1914 in 1914 some of the social or
the mainstream of the Italian Socialist
Party was against Italy entering the war
they wanted Italy to maintain their
neutrality but you had splinter groups
more nationalist groups that said hey
look this is Italy's this is Italy's
chance to claim what it's what it's
right it should join the war on the
inside of the ant ant and Mussolini was
one of these individuals and because of
his his strong pro-war stance he was
actually kicked out of his huge head of
a socialist paper in 1914 and then he
eventually by 1915 establishes the fasci
di sione revolution area and by the end
of World War one as we get into 1919 it
regroups under the name fasci italiani
de combate amento so this literally
translates as you could view fasci as a
group or league or revolutionary league
of italians of combatants or or the
combatant Italian revolutionary group I
guess is one way to think about the
Italian the the group of Italian
combatants is another way to think about
it and their their ideology and their
ideology wasn't well established when
what right when they set up it was just
really around this idea that of being
super Pro nationalist but it began to
develop over the course of the 20s and
the 1930s the core idea and I've already
said it multiple times is kind of an
extreme nationalism extreme nationalism
and when we talk about extreme
nationalism or nationalism in general
it's talking about the the interests of
one nation of one group above all others
about putting the state above all other
things
oftentimes fascism is viewed as a
right-wing group but in its purest form
it's neither left or right wing at the
left end of the spectrum you could
imagine communist or socialism I'll
write communism which is kind of you can
do as an extreme form of socialism
communism and at the extreme right you
could imagine you know just complete
free
market complete unfettered free market
ultra ultra small government and
fascists and extreme nationalists they
didn't view themselves as either end of
the spectrum they kind of viewed
themselves as a separate way where
everything was subordinate the economy
itself was subordinate to the state now
with that said they tended to align
themselves more with folks on the right
so even though they weren't completely
free market capitalists they were
staunchly anti-communist an anti
Socialist which caused them to form
alliances a little bit more with the
right but from their point of view it
wasn't one of these extreme right-wing
ideologies that the government should be
subordinate to the economy that the
government should be as small as
possible it was much more that the
economy was was there to serve national
interests some of the other kind of
ideologies that the fascists began to
hold is this idea that force was a
legitimate part of politics so force in
politics and you we see this wouldn't
Benito Mussolini's fascists through the
use of the black shirts which was their
paramilitary group which allowed them to
eventually take political control and
enforce political control and we later
see it with other groups like the Nazis
who are also tended to be associated
with fascism and their storm troopers
and their storm battalions their
paramilitary forces that are used to
essentially take political control the
other aspect of them and as you can
imagine when we're talking about either
Mussolini or the Nazis is that they
weren't really fans of democracy that
they really not only did they think that
everything should be subordinate to the
state but that the state should have
absolute control so it's not about
democracy it's about having a strong
leader at the top a strong one party at
the top and in the case of of Mussolini
it was a fascist in the case of Hitler
it ends up being the Nazis so
totalitarian completely totalitarian and
then they also on these kind of all
gelled together this idea of aggressive
foreign policy and that's aggressive
foreign policy is really in is rooted in
this belief of cultural superiority and
if you take the case of the not
seize this belief in racial extreme
racial superiority cultural superiority
and I'm making a slight distinction
there because in Mussolini's eyes he was
actually quite disparaging even though
Hitler looked to Mussolini as a
something of a role model when Mussolini
took power in 1922 it inspired Hitler's
Beer Hall pooched Mussolini did not
think much of Hitler through much of the
1920s and even early 1930s he thought
Hitler's ideas of racial racial purity
were really an illusion that there was
no racially pure race he didn't really
appreciate Hitler calling the Italians a
mongrel race but Mussolini himself did
think that the Italians were culturally
superior and that would be their
justification for an aggressive foreign
policy for them taking over other other
territory in in Europe and and in Africa
and as we'll see because they shared so
much in common
ideologically the Nazis were you could
kind of view as a more extreme form and
the fascists themselves were quite
extreme but the Nazis were a more
extreme form of this of the same
ideology they will even though in the
20s and early 30s Mussolini is more
eager to to align himself with some of
the other powers in Europe in particular
Great Britain in France as we go into
the second half of 1930s Mussolini in
not and Hitler find themselves to be
kindred spirits they both want to be
aggressive in their foreign policy they
both want to secure other territory they
both have this idea that they need space
for their superior populations to
they're culturally superior and in the
case of the Nazis racial the superior
populations to grow and thrive and so as
we enter into the second half of the
1930s and World War two the the you have
Mussolini and the fascists become close
allies of Hitler and the Nazis